[Musica]
buonasera nel nel 2018
abbiamo intervistato da uno dei
quotidiani più importanti in svizzera le
noie zurich zeitung e il giornalista mi
chiedeva di conto di alcune scelte di
consumo apparentemente bizzarre quali
quelle di un cittadino svizzero che
aveva comprato una targa con una
particolare numerazione spendendo
l'equivalente di 150 mila euro per la
targa non per l'auto e il
l'intervistatore mi come dire aveva
contattato perché l'ha letto dei miei
articoli di cui ancora oggi lavoro su
cui ancora oggi lavoro su quelle che si
chiamano beni posizionali che sono
particolari beni economici che hanno
valore che sono di valore per
l'individuo se non sono accessibili per
altri anzi acquistano di valore se altri
non possono accedere acquistarli
comprarli ecco questo caso di questa
targa di questo sito di questo cittadino
svizzero e comprare questo tipo di targa
rientra all'interno dei beni posizionali
il cittadino svizzero crea un divario un
divario tra lui che può scegliere la
targa e permettersi di pagare quella
cifra esosa e chi non può la scelta di
beni posizionale è una scelta che non
vale solo per italia vale per tantissimi
beni di consumo
facciamo questo tipo di scelte quando
parliamo quando scegliamo gioielli in
svizzera anche quando si scelgono gatti
di razza ecco perché lo vedete nella
foto quando scegliamo gli smartphone
quando scegliamo le nostre case quando
scegliamo anche la stessa automobile
evidenza empirica ci dice che quando
quando compriamo un auto non guardiamo
solo le esigenze che abbiamo derivanti
da quell'auto ma guardiamo anche le
scelte di consumo o di non consumo nei
nostri vicini e quindi siamo disposti a
comprare un'auto un po più costosa se
quello vuol dire avere l'auto più grande
e più bella più fiammeggiante
ecco io su questo voglio provare a
parlarvi è brevemente
e in particolare cercare di spiegarvi
cercate di mostrarvi sia lati negativi
sia ai lati positivi di questo tipo di
consumo
cominciamo da quelli negativi
john maynard keynes
aveva previsto che grazie allo sviluppo
economico grazie allo sviluppo
tecnologico
avremmo avuto una maggiore facilità
minor costo per accedere a certi tipi di
beni se vogliamo beni necessari
essenziali della nostra vita e quindi
questo voleva dire che potevamo dedicare
meno tempo per lavorare anzi lui dice
che entro il 2030
avremo lavorato al massimo 15 ore a
settimana
dall'altra parte vedete invece thor
serve ben lui diceva che una volta
saziati beni necessari i beni essenziali
ci porteremo a consumare a domandare
beni posizionali per avere il cellulare
più moderno l'auto più grande la casa
come un locale in più
ecco questo però produce degli effetti
negativi effetti negativi sono che se
dedichiamo più tempo al lavoro di
richiamo meno tempo alle relazioni
sociali relazioni familiari aveva cinque
gli amici e probabilmente al nono tempo
per noi stessi e siamo diventati
potremmo diventare ancora di più una
società di monadi con molti problemi di
interazione sociale oppure se
l'individuo non è disposto a lavorare di
più
cosa fa per comprare i beni posizionali
si indebita e c'è un forte indebitamento
per certi tipi di beni di consumo e
quindi si espone a certi tipi di rischi
per quanto riguarda disagi economici che
di disagio sociale
ecco allora ci siamo domandati insieme
al professor ugo pagano che menziono con
estremo piacere perché è grazie a lui se
mi sono avvicinato a questi tipi di
riflessioni a queste analisi di questi
tipi di beni siamo domandati in che modo
possiamo bloccare limitare regolare
questo tipo di consumo e soprattutto i
suoi effetti negativi ne abbiamo
individuati principalmente tre il primo
che è un modo classico che hanno di
ragionare gli economisti se vogliamo
limitare un certo tipo di comportare
certo tipo di scelta tassiamo la ecco
che esistono comunque si possono
giustificare certi tipi di tassazione
sui beni di lusso pensate il superbollo
sulle auto di grossa cilindrata
oppure il secondo meccanismo che forse
era quello che più ci interessava a me
che a ugo pagano tra quello di
introdurre delle regole che potessero
intervenire almeno in via indiretta su
questo tipo di consumi che vuol dire
vuol dire che se il problema o se uno
dei problemi è che c'è una forte aumento
o gli individui sono spinti a lavorare
di più per comprare beni posizionali
allora è bene che ci sia una normativa
delle regole molto stringenti
sull'orario di lavoro e che imponga dei
tetti oltre i quali non è più salubre
lavorare terzo meccanismo ancora regole
ma queste per via diretta cioè
intervenire direttamente sul consumo di
questo tipo di beni già i romani con
quelle che chiamavano che si chiamano
l'ex suntuaria intervenivano su alcuni
tipi di consumi che portavano o che
erano finalizzati a creare distinzione
per esempio per quanto riguarda i
banchetti nelle cerimonie nelle feste le
famiglie romane potevano spendere quindi
organizzare questi banchetti ma non
dovevano spendere troppo c'era un tetto
in termini di sesterzi proprio perché
altrimenti sarebbe diventato un modo per
distinguersi
un po come la targa del nostro del
cittadino svizzero questo valeva per per
i banchetti valeva per gli abiti tipo di
stoffa addirittura il colore la leva per
i gioielli e valeva per l'antica roma ma
valeva che un antica grecia o trovate
l'ex quelle che i romani che amano l'ex
suntuaria anche nella natia grecia le
trovate anche tra i maya precolombiani
le trovate nel giappone imperiale delle
trovate nell'inghilterra di cromo e li
trovate
nella francia napoleonica e quindi c'è
ma un attimo con l'editto di jean claude
buona parte aveva una parte
introduciamo alex suntuaria su un
particolare ambito le opere funebri
stabilisce che non ci debbano essere
differenze e distinzioni di vari post
mortem in questo caso cioè non ci
dovessero essere individui persone che
spendevano risorse esose per
costruire statue pittore o particolari
opere murali
dall'altra parte invece vedete ugo
foscolo ugo foscolo e tra gli
intellettuali che si oppone a questo
tipo di normativa di norma di l'ex sub
to aria
anzi il suo uno dei suoi più importanti
oltre più importanti opere di sepolcri
può rappresentare implicitamente
un manifesto il manifesto a difesa del
consumo dei beni posizionali per ugo
foscolo importante che invece le
distinzioni ci siano anche post mortem
cioè tra chi è un personaggio e chi non
è un personaggio
lui aveva in mente il
la chiesa di santa croce a firenze dove
sono sepolti i grandi michelangelo
vittorio alfieri lo stesso ugo foscolo e
pensava alla questi luoghi come luoghi
dove l'italiano comunque la persona
doveva andare per trovare o ispirarsi
nei suoi modelli e quindi era importante
invece crea quindi creare differenze
creare distinzioni anche post mortem
è questo che volete e ancora oggi
presente nella nostra società anzi è
molto sviluppata la nostra società se
pensate alle gerarchie che si trova
all'interno delle organizzazioni
individuo se volete i lavoratori
concorrono competono l'un l'altro per
emergere per diventare il migliore per
poi essere promosso la categoria
superiore vale per i lavoratori ma vale
anche per giulio cesare è un po che
questo il titolo del mio intervento
plutarco fa dire a giulio cesare che
passa in un villaggio di barbari galli
meglio essere il primo tra questi
barbari che secondo a roma c'è giulio
cesare dispone è disposto a rinunciare
alla già tezza alla ricchezza di roma
panem et circensem dicevano i romani per
stare in un posto molto più povero molto
più di
come dire limitato che era la gallia ma
essere il primo
ora la storia ci dice anche che lilo
cesare non si è fermato in gallia
diventato il primo 3 barbari ma
diventato soprattutto il primo tra i
primi a roma
e questo ci dice che quando facciamo
questo tipo di riflessioni ci occupiamo
di un contesto ma raggiunto quel
contesto cioè una volta che siamo
diventati magari i primi abbiamo un
riferimento ancora più alto o cerchiamo
a un riferimento ancora più alto come se
corressimo su un rullo cioè senza fine
corressimo ci rincorre stimo sul rullo
male per i grandi condottieri vale per
gli individui vale anche per gli angeli
e sempre in maniera romanzata john
milton fa dire al suo chief ero meglio
governare
all'inferno che il posto più disagiato
per definizione che rehn che che servire
in paradiso di nuovo una dinamica per
cui abbiamo necessità anche gli angeli
hanno necessità di distinguersi di
emergere
e concludo con un'ultima che positiva
che è una
una
una rappresentazione una cartolina ecco
una cartolina da san gimignano san
geminiano e famosa per le sue torri
oggi se ne possono ammirare circa una
ventina in passato erano all'incirca 1
si riporta che se fosse la ricerca
un'ottantina queste teorie non hanno
finalità militari non sono costruite
sulla cinta muraria non hanno finalità
abitative anzi in alcuni casi erano
utilizzate come delle prigioni hanno
un'unica finalità che poi quella che era
la finalità del tizio che compra la
targa pagandola 150 mila euro cioè
ostentare segnalare la ricchezza
l'opulenza della famiglia che realizzava
questa torre
tra l'altro le torri queste torri
secondo me sono un'ottima
rappresentazione del divario
che sottende ogni tipo di bene
posizionale cioè la distanza tra
individuo che sta a terra ad individuo
che sta in cima e tanto più c'è questa
di stasera è tanto di più la torre alta
tanto più quel bene vale c'è diventa
posizionare fino ad arrivare magari a
essere la famiglia che ha il la torre
più alta
e qui voglio lasciare con una questione
una domanda domanda poi non so
rispondere che forse trasmette da
ragione anche per cui continua ad
occuparmi di questi temi ma guardando
questa cartolina uno potrebbe dire beh
diciamo la concorrenza perché viene
posizionali
porta degli effetti negativi o perlomeno
questo tipo di risorse economiche non
economiche per realizzare queste torri
potevano essere spesi meglio
per le stesse famiglie o per il contesto
e allora sarebbe bene che esistessero
regole o meccanismi che limitassero
questo tipo di consumo questo tipo di
scelte oppure e questa la domanda
guardando questa cartolina forse
potremmo dire beh per fortuna che c'è
una concorrenza per i beni posizionare
perché poi a distanza di secoli
noi oggi possiamo ammirare magari
visitare uno dei posti più ambiti e
belli al mondo grazie